[Musica]
vi siete mai fatti bendare
io sì è una delle tante pratica che
faccio con il mio compagno con i miei
partner per divertirmi a letto
la band è una forma di botas contagio
significa privare la persona della
propria libertà
molte persone pensano che sia
semplicemente fregare dei pozzi o negare
una persona ha detto invece no significa
proprio togliere uno dei cinque sensi
anche quindi nel caso della menta stiamo
togliendo la vista
quello che accade quando togliamo la
vista che gli altri sensi li metterò
molto più ricettivi quindi nel momento
in cui per commentata
l'udito e il tatto diventano molto più
attenti a ciò che sta accadendo attorno
è una forma anche di autodifesa dobbiamo
controllare cosa abbiamo attorno
il botto si appartiene al bdsm che un
acronimo che sta a indicare al punto
potes disciplina
dominazione e sottomissione sadismo e
masochismo è una una cronico che
appartiene alla sessualità che viene
definita alternativa
insolita alternativa quella che
tradizionale quella classica
entrambe sono sono valide entrambe su di
verdetti sono due modi per esplorare la
propria sessualità
io nello specifico una fetish per il
volto giapponese insegna bondage
giapponese insegne quindi alla gente a
legale il proprio partner la propria
partner con le corde
esistono varie tipologie di bond a suo
appunto facendo con le cotte che arriva
dal giappone un paese povero di materie
prime
e la differenza non è soltanto il
materiale assodate si usano tema e
quindi li ferma millennio la classica
gogna ma la grossa differenza sa che
nella fantasia
in occidente cioè che la fantasia del
movimento mentre in giappone si pensa
più al 7 colpa che per loro è un po
diverso anche l'espiazione
vi racconterò una cosa un po personale
io sono siciliana e non amo il contatto
fisico per niente
in sicilia anche nella sconosciuti ci si
abbraccia e ci si bacia sin dal primo
momento
è una cosa che ho sempre vissuto
malissimo
l'ho sempre ho sempre cercato di
allontanarmi nel momento in cui una
persona si avvicinava poi lo faccio
pubblicata faccio io con il botto
giapponese non parla di una nuova forma
di contatto
è un contatto che non avviene subito con
il corpo avviene prima con la corda
della persona che vi sta legando
il conto su appartiene ai giochi di
ruolo
spesso le persone pensano a chi è dio i
giochi da tavolo che quelle persone si
vessero un determinato tipo di
abbigliamento interpreta il personaggio
anche io faccio questo pro faccio quella
sessualità a me piace assolutamente mio
compagno ed entrare all'interno di una
fantasia in cui io sono una persona
sottomessa vi lascio fare qualcosa ma
soprattutto lascia la mia fiducia
quell'altra persona
sia fisicamente perché oggettivamente
che potrebbe succedere qualsiasi cosa
anche psicologicamente perché collegata
sono otto tra gi
le corde viaggiano il corpo in una
posizione scomoda
stressante fisicamente e questo fa
nascere delle fantasie
spesso quando ben collegato delle
emozioni molto forti perché
perduta dalla mia emotività dalle mie
esperienze passate dei ricordi le faccio
diventare fantasie spesso sono fantasie
molto molto cupe però mentito
ho dovuto fare
8 con questa cosa perché ci insegnano
che le cose più peccati e bisogna
io invece ho scoperto che sono eccitanti
e che se le facce in un determinato
momento
ecco consapevolezza non c'è niente di
male
quello che veramente sono legata e che
appunto vivo un tormento interiore posto
forte
maestro giapponese
yu kimura segnava moda
diceva che chi sta legando che realizza
mente la personal vinante accompagna una
persona sottomessa attraverso il viaggio
delle proprie fantasie erotiche spesso
neanche ad esami non è detto che le due
persone abbiano la stessa fantasia
io ho spesso di confronto con il mio
compagno o le persone che legano click
che leggo perché anche io leggo che le
fantasie non combacia però entrambi ci
siamo fatti un trip
incredibile eccitante per entrambi
questa sì magari si sono toccate
pochissimo
precisano gli ostili abbiamo vissuto in
un terminale un momento attraverso il
nostro corpo
nelle situazioni molto forti eccitanti
ma anche tormentate
in giappone c'è una grossa differenza
tra la sacralizzazione e intimità
non so se avete mai visto siete stati in
giappone metropolita stanno stretti
stanno veramente in un quadratino
all'interno della metropolitana loro
sono tantissimi e ovviamente si toccano
più di quegli altri che come se non si
toccassero quando sono state in giappone
questa cosa che l'ha lasciata e subito
tantissimo perché vivevano nel loro
spazio e se proprio che tornano avessero
niente
il giappone non ci si so che il naso e
pubblico
perché i fluidi corporei devono essere
detto usano la mascherina usa quando c'è
la prima la mascherina per questo motivo
se si devono soffrire il vaso qualche
bagno turco steri non si sa che le cose
ciò che è dentro le strade
la corda che vedete si chiama scimé in
aula e una corda che c'è attorno ai
templi ma viene messa che attorno a
degli oggetti
che hanno più o meno anche più di 100
anni e delimita l'area sacra
dall'esterno
e quindi nel momento in cui etna
all'interno di un tempio superano quella
corda entra in uno spazio in cui tutto è
diverso
fuori c'è il casino che adele vittorio è
una città veramente caos all'interno c'è
un silenzio incredibile e facciate la
cerimonia del tè e giappone così è un
lato venta circo
rumorosissimo dall'altro la trovata
cerimoniale il tempo una disciplina che
ti fa stare all'interno di quel momento
perché piace paragonare la corda alla
nostra pelle
abbiamo circa due metri quadri di pelle
adoces significa che noi siamo
costantemente a contatto con l'aria e
col pavimento con due metri quadri di l
e la pelle è un coma involucro è un
organo
sensibilissimo ma anche resistente si
può lascerà racing strisce piuttosto in
fretta ed è ciò che ci separa da dentro
il dentro e il fuori
e la paragona un po alla corda perché in
realtà quando leggo quanto è collegata
la corda aumenta le sensazioni che io
provo che vengono passate dalla persona
che vi sta legato a me attraverso la
corda non è detto che tocchi in un certo
modo il mio corpo ma attraverso la corda
mi sta passando qualcosa sta passando di
messaggio
viene messa una corda la persona si
allontana
c'è anche un contatto quella persona si
allontana e cerca di passaggi passate a
me il messaggio attraverso quel buon
contatto si dice e si comunica anche
stanno in silenzio e si comunica anche
non toccando le persone è una forma di
contatto giusto comunque comunica vuole
cose spesso di molto brutto un
attraverso il contatto mandato qualcuno
gli dia conforto
passiamo un messaggio
e io quando quando vivo questo tormento
molto forte che le scelte in maniera
consapevole di vivere che io canto danza
classica salva solo dalla padella alla
brace
sono passata da stare sulle punte su un
palco ricade su vado e insegnarlo in
tutto il mondo
in realtà
e così ho riscoperto una forma di
contatto che non conoscevo
perché è una forma di contatto che passa
attraverso le fantasie della persona che
passa attraverso le vie fantasia
quando vengo slegata c'è un vero
contatto fisico ed è quello che mi fa
passare delle emozioni molto molto forti
spesso la persona che vi spiega mi sta
accudendo spesso vista che li citando
ea me piace quel rifiuto
spesso ci dimentichiamo anche fare i
cattivi non è una cosa cosi brutta
se all'interno di un gioco
oggi ci stanno forse un po
allontanando da
dalle fantasie perché tutto deve essere
censurato
io penso che la fantasia e non imposto
in cui dovranno essere un po più liberi
e io quando sono legata sono molto molto
più libera che in questo momento mentre
risultargli sulla sedia
quello che succede è che viene che si
crea con la persona che vi sta arrivando
sembrando una storia che se le due cose
non si toccano siamo credo non abbia
letti non può che passa attraverso la
pelle
ieri ero in moto
stavo soffrendo tantissimo per arrivare
all'aquila perché scurissimo è l'unico
modo per arrivare fin qui era separare
il dolore fisico che stavo provando in
quel momento
farlo entrare dentro il mio uomo per
sentire le la mia pelle
l'aria sulla pelle
se ci pensate quando qualcuno si
avvicina attraverso i peli alla
vicinanza quelli veri
sentiamo che qualcuno si sta avvicinando
ma che potrebbe poi non avvicinarsi
potrebbe essere una finta e ci passa un
messaggio in questa cosa
era bellente di pila in questo senso è
un involucro che però separa veramente
in pericolo esterno da quello che c'è
dentro che non sono solo gli organi
perché non siamo solo orna ne abbiamo le
fantasie dei pensieri avevo l'intimità
io quest'anno intimità la scoperta
attraverso la sofferenza
per me è sempre difficile parlare di
sofferenza perché la gente pensa che sia
sbagliato sul 7 che il dolore non deve
esistere lo dobbiamo cancellare
completamente
eppure attraverso il dolore noi sentiamo
fermiamo lo stomaco cinema nello stomaco
fa c'è lo stop o graffiata ho iniziato a
calco la pelle la7 altrimenti non lo non
facciamo sì percepiamo di essere scomodi
e veloci siamo sull'altra ghiaccio
perché ci accorgiamo solo in quel
momento di avere un po
la immagino che conoscete tutti la
favola della principessa sul pisello
dicendo sotto se temo grassi e lei sella
c'è prova
fastidio nella liber sensibile
sassolino nella scarpa per me è peggio
di un pisello 7 magrassi
poi siamo diventati ipersensibile
qualsiasi cosa ci dà fastidio forse
dovremmo imparare a viverci questi
piccoli fastidi e a capire che siamo
all'interno di un corpo
il nostro corpo non è un taxi
però lo trattiamo così non ci rendiamo
conto che attraverso il nostro corpo
attraverso il contatto con questo corpo
mio dire non solo con la belle ma viene
anche parlando
avviene sentendo
abbiamo corpo e ci viviamo in quel corpo
non dovremmo veramente trattarlo se
fosse un'auto che ci scarrozza da un
lato all'altro
noi siamo in questo gorgo in questo
momento è questo momento non ce lo
restituirà nessuno
quello che abbiamo ascoltato oggi non ce
lo restituirà nessuno e lo dico
percepito tutti attraverso il nostro
corpo
io spero
oggi di passarvi questo messaggio per me
è semplice perché sempre sempre lavorato
con il mio corpo perché ho fatto danza
che la sigla della vita di tre anni
per 17 anni della mia vita e poi sono
passato al bondage a insegnare il poker
per me quasi scontato parlare di colpo
perché ci sono sempre presente però mi
rendo conto
lo vedrò con i miei studenti
e spesso ci dimentichiamo
che qui e ora e adesso questo che
possiamo vivere solo attraverso questo
popolo
[Applauso]